hello everyone and sorry about no videos
for the past few days I was very busy
with a real world stuff but we are
returning to the capablanca saga
you know the good stuff and we are
continuing our match against the manual
a score the 1921 match if you haven't
been with us from the beginning the
first thing you will see in the
description below is game one from this
match so you know when you talk about
with your friends and family you don't
miss out on anything but also there is a
link to the entire Capablanca saga from
the beginning from his match against one
course of the Cuban national champion up
until this point if you wanna you know
just give it a go from the beginning now
returning to the match Game one was a
draw now Alaska has the white pieces
let's see how he deals against the Cuban
with d4 by Alaska d5 back up Blanca c4
e6 sorry about that and we all know of
course where this is going with Knight
c3 and now Knight to f6 the Queens
gambit declined is on the board Knight
to f3 and now Knight B to d7 and here
Lasker plays III which is very
interesting
Capablanca says that you know the most
basic of chess principles say that you
have to develop your bishop first before
closing it with your pawn but Lasker has
a different idea he plays III but it's
interesting that Bishop to g5 is the
main line move today but you know it's
also interesting to point out that you
don't need an a like a super engine to
tell you these things if you just follow
the chess principles here and it's also
something I wanted to mention I don't
know whenever I meet a beginner like
someone who knows the rules and he
played some some games but then when I
asked him do you want to play he says no
I'm really not good at chess I don't
have any openings then you you have to
explain it to these people that it's
okay if you don't know openings openings
are for grandmasters well international
masters and grandmasters but what you
really want to learn our chess
principles and those are very easy you
don't even have to learn chess
principles because they are so so simple
I mean just you know control the center
with your pawns the Knights go into the
game before bishops rooks are you know
rooks have to control open lines and
files the rules we go
behind passed pawns don't bring your
queen out too early and so on and so on
and when you follow this basic set of
shots principles you will play a certain
opening you know even if even if you
don't know any openings I just wanted to
mention that Alberto Callaspo goes for
e3 I will push up to be better please
seven back up one cut Bishop to d3 both
players Castle and now we have D
captures on c4 which is something that
it's you know played very often even
today with Bishop captures on c4 and now
c5 attacking the center you want to play
a 6 b5 next and well now just see what
her white will do we have Queen to e2 by
Lasker and now a6 couple Monica prepares
b5 and now rook to d1 with b5 by couple
Anka grabbing more space on the Queen
side Bishop to d3 and now Bishop to b7
this light square bishop assumes the
most important diagonal in the game and
it's often when you play the Queens
gambit the client with the black pieces
your biggest problem would be how to get
to the light square Bishop you know
fully operational and here kappa blanka
already did that and move 11 which is
something that might have something to
do with Lasker not playing you know
according to the principles he left his
bishop undeveloped on c1 which is
something he will have to rectify and
capablanca mentions that the only reason
in his opinion to play pawn to e3 before
actually developing the Bishop g5 is if
you wanna maybe play something like b3
and develop the bishop to fianchetto it
on the Queen side but doing something
like that now wouldn't really go your
way for example if b3 you you can just
play C capture Sun before it captures
and rook c8 you know okay Bishop to b2
you've developed your dark square bishop
but now Queen to a5 already there's
there are a lot of problems here for
white well for one there's the threat of
rook captures on c3 so after you defend
it now you've left your a 2 point
unguarded you're gonna bring another
attacker to the c3 Knight and well
obviously white already made some sort
of a mistake because it's black who's
attacking it's black who's pushing and
you don't really have to throw for
anything with the white pieces now you
have to move the knight and black and
just win material captures here captures
captures captures you can snatch the
pawn on a to your
already attacking the b3 pawn and white
well we'll probably lose this game
so here after Bishop to be seven by
couple uncle Oscar pushes efore he's now
ready to develop the dark square Bishop
you know much later than then he
probably should have we have C capture
son d4 Knight capture son d4 and now
Knights the e5 a great move by
capablanca threatening to take away last
prepare and he's not worried about the
Queen being on the same file as the rock
here because even if Lasker plays Bishop
captures on b5 captors and Knight
captures on e6 seems very dangerous yes
the Queen is under attack but once you
move the Queen let the Queen behave you
can capture the rook there's really no
better move characters captures and you
don't have a good compensation for for
the sacrifice material okay but before
you can go b4 attack the knight Knight
d5 you can trade here captures captures
and yes why does have a passed pawn here
but you're just gonna block it and with
the would couple on has superior bishop
repair and the position being in blacks
favor should have the upper hand here so
capablanca not worried about any tactics
of this kind with Knight to b3 by Lasker
and now Capablanca just trades with
Knight captures rook captures and Queen
to c7 getting the Queen out of the way
and well this Bishop is already nicely
eyeing the king now the Queen does the
same
so Capablanca is ready to play in the
center on the Kings side on the Queen
side everything is good for black here
and here still Alaska really can't
develop with Bishop to g5 this dark
square Bishop really is giving him a lot
of problems because after h6 now you can
okay you can trade for the night which
isn't something you want to do but if
you move it then Knight captures a need
for just win the pawn if Bishop captures
you're just gonna capture on c3 attack
the Queen and after you capture here the
Queen captures on e7 and if you come to
the pawns Capablanca is now up upon so
there are still not able to develop for
well the way you would want to develop
so with E 5 by Lasker now okay you do
disruptor whites blacks pieces
coordination but on the other hand it
will be somewhat difficult to defend the
upon that is now already an e5 we have
Knight to d5 and an Outlook to g3 Lasker
says okay this is a very nice attacking
piece it's also a very nice defending
piece since the guards g2 I really want
to play Bishop to h6 and we start to
start an attack against the black king
first couple Blanca captures on c3
attacks the Queen so you have to react
to this and you also don't want to allow
some some battery creation with Queen to
c6 then white would be forced to defend
so first rook captures and c3 kicks away
the Queen we have Queen to d7 capablanca
said in his book that well he felt very
confident after playing Queen to d7 and
that he feels that blacks should now
have a superior game something I always
enjoy who win kappa blanka you know
annotates his his own games he will say
black will have a superior game here
some very very professional and very
gentleman and gentlemanly if that that's
some word but okay rook back to g3
Glasper now ready to play Bishop d6 and
now kappa blanka
in d you know expect expecting of Bishop
to h6 he moves the rook F to d8 now gets
full control of the D file and he's not
really worked because now you can put g6
without losing material with bush up to
H sets by Lasker g6 now of course
defending and now Alaska retreats Bishop
to e3 and here Alaska once couple on got
to play rook a c8 this is the last piece
that's really not doing anything so you
kind of do want to play it a rook ACA
but then Alaska will play Bishop to b6
and then kappa blanka will have to move
this rook from the great d8 square so
couple blanca doesn't want to do it he
plays Queen d5 here he's not all too
satisfied with 25 because he says it's a
move but you know now III couldn't find
any better moves and if you wanna for
example compare Coco Blanc has moved to
the top engine recommendation which is
Bishop to b5 Bishop to d5
seems like it improves the position or
the world the activity of the light
square bishop it's not all that easy to
attack this Bishop you don't have a
light-sport Bishop yourself this night
will have to waste a lot of moves to
attack the light square Bishop and it's
just an excellent piece there so yeah
perhaps another slow move would have
gone a long way for black but okay Queen
d5 capablanca says now he does have to
give up the bush repair which Alaska of
course goes for with Knights that a five
rook a to c8 now it's okay to develop
the rookin c8 Knight captures on b7
Queen captures still guarding the b6
square and now Bishop back to h6 by
Lasker which is a very nice attacking
idea if you go with rook to d1
seems normally your last girls so we
like to defend develop the light the the
rook it just loses the game because rook
captures Queen captures and rook to d8
now you have to move the Queen for
example Queen e1 and now you play Queen
to c7 and you cannot defend the e5 pawn
and also defend against the threat of
Queen to c2 followed by rook to d1
so you would lose a lot of material here
and the Indian probably the game for
example if you try and defend it with f4
just Queen c2 and there's no defense
against rogue d1 there are too many back
back ranked weaknesses so after Queen
captures on b7 with Bishop to h6 by
Lasker and now Queen back to d5 with b3
by Lasker now he can get the rook into
the game without the a 2 point being a
target and here
Queen to d4 by kappa blanka he wants to
start attacking this pawn here and he
decided to go for Queen to d4 followed
by rook to d5 the Queen makes room for
the rook
then the autoroute can also come to c5
attack the rook and perhaps later the
bishop will also join the attack against
the pawn that is now on a dark square
he says Bishop to b4 would probably have
been better because if you play Bishop
to b4 you can always go rook c5 play
Bishop to c3 which also attacks the pawn
but more importantly the bishop on this
diagonal prevents the rook from coming
to e 1 to help out with the defense of
the e5 pawn so probably a better idea
for a couple mongkhon and the engine
agrees with Capablanca we have Queen to
d4 now rooked f1 by Lasker now preparing
to move this rook play g3 and effort
really solidify in the center we have
rook to defy by capablanca going after
the pawn here and now look the e3 and
here Bishop the 8th
now with ideas of well maybe playing
Bishop to b2 to get another attacker to
the point to the e5 pawn here but g3 and
now Capablanca after thinking about the
position he plays Queen to b2 and we
already mentioned that the time control
is 15 moves per hour and this already
moved 28 so both players are forced to
make two more moves before the you know
the hour expires so here bringing
another attacker to the e5 pawn wouldn't
really work because Alaska had Queen to
f3 in mind and now if rook captures an
e5 you go Queen to the story rook to d3
and now after the Queen moves and now
you get the other look to d1 and with
the bishop slicing over here you have
well for a moment the Queen does guard
the da square but white would have a lot
of attacking opportunities here Queen to
f6 with the threat of just checkmate in
black okay the bishop for the moment
controls this diagonal but there are a
lot of there's a lot of attacking
potential for white here so a couple
Blanca doesn't like it he decides to
play Queen to b2 here and offers a queen
trade he says okay it's a weak pawn if
you want to defend it you're just gonna
have to you know play f4 at some point
and then maybe I will be able to use
this against you because then basically
Alaska is Bishop will become a bad
Bishop all of the pawns on dark squares
and a dark square Bishop not something
you want to have where as capablanca has
a dark square bishop and all of his
pawns are nicely on light squares which
means he has a good Bishop and he will
be he will have a much superior game or
just a superior game you know it's okay
rook to e1 now preparing for a queen
trade and probably capablanca says that
capturing the Queen for example followed
by Bishop to b4 would have been the best
way to go to but this is move 29 and he
really has to increase the tension so
rook to c2 just forcing Lasker to make
his last move before time control and we
have Queen to f3 Alaska pretty much the
best move there's nothing to do here
and now capablanca says he thought about
Bishop to f8 which he couldn't decide
for himself if it if it was a winning
or a losing move and he gives the exact
same line your engine will give you just
bishop capture screen captures Queen to
f6 getting the Queen into the attack
King to g8 not allowing Queen to h6 and
now just h4 and he says that black is
better here and of course the engine
agrees with capablanca but that it will
be very hard to defend this position
against Lasker as the white also has a
lot of attacking potential here so he
decides against it he plays Bishop to e7
and now rook 3 to e2 Laster now offers
some traits here and he also offers
capablanca da to pawn now feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out what to do here well basically try
to figure out is it okay to capture the
a to pawn that's what I'm asking you
here for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent not blunderer of games and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is definitely not ok to capture
the pawn because if you capture the pawn
the game is just lost you can see that
the bishop controls the C 1 square so
you just capture once and play rook c1
and it's a game over because now
whatever you play you just lose after
Queen D 3 you get rook the ch-check and
now you can block with the bishop d8
which you can block with the bishop to
f8 and you can block with rook b8 but
every move was is Bishop f8 loses to
just mate in one row captures here if
you block with the rook then it's of
course just Queen captures on d3 you
cannot recapture your rook is pinned and
if butcher blocks bishop d8 then the win
is even nicer just Queen to f6 there's
no defense against Queen to g7 mate the
bishop is now pin through cannot capture
and if after black delivers one check
just King g2
King g2 and there are no no more checks
so last girl for the pawn but it is
really quite quite a poisoned pawn so
couple Annika trades we have root
capture Sonny to rook captures I need to
and now Queen to be one and check King
to g2 lasker of course doesn't want his
King on the bank back rank the King is
much safer on g2 and only now bush up to
f8 but here Alaska declines the trade he
plays Bishop to f4 now ok this bishop
is now pretending to be a pawn but for
the moment there are no issues here with
8 6 kappa blanka would like to play g5
to kick the bishop away but h4 Lasker
doesn't allow it
with B for now keeping these pawns here
on on light squares and making da to
pawn a backward sponsor which will
remain a weakness for the rest of the
game welcome to Blanc as bishop here
nicely guards at the b4 pawn we have
Queen to e4 now last core offers a queen
trade and it's well now it's not all
that simple to decline this trade for
example if you play rook a queen d1 just
Roxy - and now you might have some
background issues of your own
so Queen captures on e4 by kappa blanka
with rook captures on e4 and now King to
g7 just improving the position of the
King with rook to c4 and now Bishop to
c5 Capablanca doesn't allow Alaska's
group to infiltrate the position with
King to f3 Lasker starts bringing his
kingdom to the game and now Capablanca
doesn't find any more wasting T in this
game so he just plays g5 he offers this
a complete tray down after which you can
just accept a draw with H captures each
character special captures and it was in
this position unmoved 41 that last brand
Capablanca agreed to a draw because
after rook captures an e5 just Bishop
back to f4 and Ruby 5 there's no way to
to actually do anything and well they it
was a gentlemanly to offer and accept a
draw here whereas if for example Magnus
Carlsen had this endgame today he would
probably play it out for fifty or a
hundred more moves that trying to grind
down something but I believe in those
days it was considered rude and you know
it was you didn't prove that your
opponent made a mistake so just grinding
out in equal position against the
against the world champion I believe was
even considered rude but who knows but
yeah definitely a drone endgame so they
agree to a draw so this is game two ends
in a draw so still very very exciting
World Chess Championship match between
manual Oscar and Jose roll kappa blanka
whereas if you've been following so far
Capablanca is basically already the
champion and
serves as the Challenger but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Jonathan brew Luke
Thomas go for Pete be yesterday was
Pete's birthday but I didn't post any
videos yesterday so sorry about that I
wish you a very happy birthday hope you
had a really good day fourth dimension
mark left Kuwait's and bear him alone
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check too on my previous
videos your think all for watching and I
will see soon most likely continue in a
couple blanca saga but also checking up
on your suggestions and such thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day